i want to start with congratulations on
the movie i thought uh everyone did such
a great job with this i'm sure you're
hearing that from everyone coming into
these rooms um i'm very curious for uh
what surprised you guys about making
like your first hollywood movie if you
will and working with people like colin
and viggo and joel you know people
that everyone sort of knows oh
allow me to translate for ploy
for her the biggest surprise to work in
a hollywood movie and working with
famous actors actors
is uh
they turned out to be very kind friendly
uh they took great care of uh thai cast
throughout the shooting
um before that you never expect that you
know someone famous can be that very
very nice it has been a very good uh
experience for both of them yeah
we are so lucky to work with ron howard
you know he's very nice to the team to
to all of us and and
yeah
he helped me everything and
yeah
all the shooting went well
one of the things that i thought ron did
such a great job with
was he didn't hollywoodize the story it
felt very authentic it felt like these
were real people and it just it just
felt like he really went for the
authenticity of each scene can you sort
of talk about that and how he directed
you to you know for that kind of emotion
for her
the authentic city of the movie came
from
ron's great effort
it started since
before the production started
when they've all flew into australia
they have to do 14 days of quarantine
and during that time they have a zoo
meeting almost every day to discuss
uh everything in details including that
character script
because one want to ensure that this
movie gonna be accurate and authentic
and ron also opened
open up to our thai actors and actress
to
share
their opinion and ron always
listen and try to take that input into
the movie
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie
what do you think uh people would be
surprised to learn about the making of
this film
uh for for them uh what they feel
impressed the most about the behind the
scene
is uh how ron and his team pay attention
to the details of everything from the
prop
the diving gears
the costumes
everything in details
were discussed
and
many products need to be imported from
thailand to ensure that
uh
people are convinced that this is the
shooting in thailand why would it
actually shoot in australia
[Music]
and he also shared the inside of his
team uh ron uh brought them to see
every single department who are working
behind the scene to to let them get to
learn like how how all the crew work
together
i'm actually curious what was it like
for both of you to actually watch this
film for the first time
and see yourself in like a hollywood
movie like this you know like what what
was that like for both of you
i feel like wow
house handsome
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah i i appreciate i i i i appreciate
to work with great people it's
it's beautiful
it's very beautiful to me
[Music]
for her the first moment that she saw
herself in ron's movie
is she feel very proud that she's a part
of this great movie
and she also feel happy that she's a
part of the people who tell
a wonderful story to the world
and tell the world that
this good story can really happen in
real life the thing that i find so
amazing about this story is that if all
of these people did not come together
and work together um i think that it
would have been a very bad outcome it
was only because of
the world coming together um can you
sort of talk about that how it was
really this group effort that saved
these people
for her the miracle is human mad
it is not something
given by the god
it's because of everyone coming together
just like you said
and
when it comes to
the humanity
uh
it is nothing related to the nationality
or who you are but
it's
about the common interest
that
you want to be kind and you share the
love to
uh
the human um i'm out of time i i just
wanted to say congratulations i hope the
film is a huge hit and i wish you guys
nothing but the best
thank you
you